[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
hablar de un debate que cada vez llama
más la atención y es el papel de la
Inteligencia artificial en nuestro mundo
se trata de una tecnología que según
expertos no tiene freno y de hecho es
uno de los avances más notables de
nuestra época el lanzamiento de
herramientas como chat gpt o la
competencia truck
y con cada vez más piezas artísticas
realizadas por Inteligencia artificial e
incluso una presentadora de noticias
Cuba Haití enteramente diseñada por
algoritmos el debate se vuelve más
interesante sobre Cómo aprender a
convivir con esta tecnología Pero además
expertos alertan que uno de los
problemas que enfrenta el planeta ni
siquiera tiene que ver con la presencia
de la Inteligencia artificial sino con
la brecha que genera su ausencia en
algunas sociedades
la Inteligencia artificial usa la
información que tiene y si solo unas
partes del mundo digitalizan su
información entonces se centrará en esas
partes del mundo lo que no se ha
registrado puede ser en artes puede ser
en países en desarrollo no será visible
Así que básicamente la Inteligencia
artificial amplificará y acelerará lo
que viene de esos países que contribuyan
mientras que las otras naciones se Irán
alejando y creo que ese es uno de los
principales riesgos
hace poco fue noticia que El fotógrafo
alemán boriselda Se ganó un importante
premio de fotografía con una imagen
creada por Inteligencia artificial
rechazó el galardón y explicó que los
jurados del premio sabían que la pieza
fue cocreada con esta tecnología al
tiempo dijo que su intención al
inscribir esta foto en el concurso era
acelerar el debate sobre la legitimidad
del arte creado por este tipo de
tecnología
la belleza de generar con Inteligencia
artificial Es que solo describes con
palabras lo que quieres como resultado
eso puede ser simple o muy complejo una
artesanía en sí misma ese texto se llama
prompt así alimentas a la Inteligencia
artificial para crear la imagen
para mí como artista es una liberación
de cualquier restricción no importa el
presupuesto las locaciones
por primera vez no creamos una idea de
algo que nos gustaría tener como una
tostadora y luego la construimos solo
empezamos y no sabemos lo que vamos a
obtener puede estar lleno de sorpresas
cada vez son más las piezas generadas
por Inteligencia artificial y así como
muchos artistas consideran esta
tecnología como una herramienta
fundamental otros abogan por entender
que no se puede comparar el arte humano
con lo que es producido por un algoritmo
hay artistas que pintan por meses o
semanas siempre habrá una diferencia
entre una pintura hecha a mano y una
generada por Inteligencia artificial
Espero que Los Amantes del arte
diferencienden eso
esta muestra usa Inteligencia artificial
generadora de un algoritmo particular
que he estado desarrollando durante 10
años
siempre escuché esta preocupación sobre
si es arte humano arte de Inteligencia
artificial arte visual creo que hay un
problema muy común para quienes empujen
los límites de la imaginación cualquiera
que empuje hacia avances a ir a la
vanguardia con estas nuevas herramientas
aplicaciones
de imitar el lenguaje humano y producir
textos con simples indicaciones han
generado preocupación porque no siempre
las respuestas son exactas de hecho es
muy simple que estas plataformas creen
productos con tendencias determinadas
dependiendo de lo que se les pida y esto
se publique como información verdadera
cuando realmente están propagando datos
falsos así como la Inteligencia
artificial genera contenidos incluso
puede generar a los presentadores de
contenidos como en White news donde feda
producto de esta tecnología es
conductora
el impacto de la Inteligencia artificial
no se limitará a la prensa y a los
medios solamente se extenderá a todos
los ámbitos
con el uso del chat por ejemplo Editores
y escritores pueden generar un reporte
en tres minutos como resultado es
posible que el número de auditores
disminuya en el futuro lo que es cierto
es que la Inteligencia artificial traerá
cambios y no podemos predecir
exactamente cómo moldearán el futuro
hace poco fue famosa una supuesta
entrevista realizada por una revista
alemana al campeón mundial de Fórmula 1
Michael schumacher un producto en el que
fue una Inteligencia artificial la que
dio las respuestas imitando al piloto
que no aparecen público desde 2013 tras
sufrir un accidente de esquí es Entonces
cuando investigadores y expertos alertan
sobre la necesidad de regulaciones
esta tecnología es muy buena creando
información falsa en última instancia la
tecnología permite producir texto que
suena muy plausible y una de las formas
en que puede usarlo si no tienes
escrúpulos Es industrializar la
producción de noticias falsas
necesitamos potencialmente una
regulación necesitamos que las personas
que promueven estos productos sean
cuidadosas con cómo los venden o si los
promocionan como algo bueno también
necesitamos responsabilizarnos como
usuarios ser cuidadosos y asegurarnos de
no sobre confiar en sistemas los
expertos coinciden en que hay una
responsabilidad compartida de una parte
de los desarrolladores a la hora de
explicar Las verdaderas capacidades de
este tipo de productos pero también de
los usuarios Al momento de verificar las
fuentes de las que sale la información
de hecho están ustedes seguros de
verificar la información que consumen
hasta aquí este espacio gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros en
France 24 y France 24 punto com
[Música]